[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
so sieht krieg aus unwirklich beinahe
wie aus einem videospiel russlands
truppen rücken auf tier vor sind an zwei
stellen offenbar bereits in der stadt
auch so sieht krieg aus unter der erde
u-bahn-schächte heizungskeller werden
zur letzten zuflucht für tausende sie
starren auf ihre handy bildschirme um
mitzubekommen was da oben aus ihrer
heimat wird das leben in unserer
modernen digitalen welt über nacht
zurückgeworfen auf den horror
vergangener jahrhunderte
guten abend hinein es könnte der am
intensivsten
dokumentierte krieg werden in der
geschichte tatsächlich gibt es im netz
jetzt bereits abertausende
videoschnipsel
augenzeugenberichte
satellitenfotos aber es gibt auch viel
desinformation und gezielte
falschmeldungen viel zu viel ist immer
noch unklar wie immer wenn gekämpft wird
was wir wissen und was das jetzt für
unsere welt bedeutet werden wir ihnen in
den kommenden 45 minuten zeigen wir
beginnen mit der russischen offensive
die vor allem der ukrainischen
hauptstadt kiew gilt und mit oliver
reichert
die reste eines russischen militärjets
im kers abgestürzt oder abgeschossen für
die ukrainischen verteidiger ein erfolg
für die bewohner der häuser in der
umgebung ein schock
es gab ein geräusch irgendwas ist über
uns geflogen ich bin zum fenster
gegangen habe aber nichts gesehen ich
hatte glück nach der explosion konnte
ich fensterscheiben von beiden seiten
herunter fallen sehen immerhin wurde
hier niemand verletzt
in der nacht schlagen in kiew
wohngebieten auch raketen ein obwohl die
russischen streitkräfte behaupten nur
militärische ziele anzugreifen
ich habe geschlafen plötzlich gab es
eine laute explosion
ich würde drei meter aus dem raum
geschleudert in den flur
die russischen verbände rücken vor allem
aus dem norden und dem nordosten auf die
hauptstadt vor auf dem weg dorthin
werden zahlreiche gefechte gemeldet auch
in kiew selbst im nördlichen vorort
oberlohn soll es zu kämpfen gekommen
sein in oberlin filmen anwohner wie ein
russischer panzer ein zivil auto
überrollt der fahrer überlebt wie durch
ein wunder in der nähe liegt ein
umkämpfter luftwaffenstützpunkt
die ukrainischen truppen gelten als
deutlich unterlegen trotzdem behaupten
sie hunderte russischer soldaten getötet
und viele ihrer panzer und flugzeuge
zerstört zu haben der ukrainische
präsident fordert mehr unterstützung
heute morgen verteidigen wir unser land
ganz allein wie schon gestern die
mächtigsten kräfte der welt schauen nur
zu haben die sanktionen russland von
irgendwas überzeugt wir sehen es an
unserem himmel und fühlen ist an unserem
boden es ist nicht genug
derzeit sind laut
un-flüchtlingshilfswerk rund 100.000
flüchtlinge in der ukraine unterwegs wie
hier an der grenze zu rumänien an allen
übergängen zu westlichen ländern bringen
sich tausende frauen und kinder in
sicherheit die männer müssen bleiben um
ihr land zu verteidigen
am mittag kommen aus dem kreml
kurzzeitig versöhnliche töne man sei zu
verhandlungen bereit auch aus dem
regierungssitz der ukraine kommt ein
gesprächs vorschlag wirklich
aufgegriffen werden diese ideen heute
aber nicht
so beginnt nun die zweite nacht im krieg
und die menschen suchen wieder schutz in
den u-bahn-stationen vor ihnen liegt
eine nacht voller unsicherheit und angst
und wir gehen jetzt direkt ins
stadtkrankenhaus nach kiew zudem metro
mias nie kauf erst notfallmediziner dort
herr doktor guten abend können sie uns
sagen wie viele opfer des krieges sie
jetzt bereits behandeln mussten
kann nur über unser krankenhaus sprechen
hatten sie hier
17 personen gehabt die schusswaffen
verletzungen gehabt haben ich weise das
in anderen krankenhäusern auch er
verletzte gibt
insbesondere
und das ist das schlimmste kinder
in
unserem krankenhaus haben wir ja sein
kind 13 jahre alt
auch mit schussverletzungen
während seiner verletzung
leider sind die eltern umgekommen
wir haben das kind wir haben die oma des
kindes gefunden
zum glück
hat das geht zumindest
die oma als verwandtschaft ich nehme an
auch sie ihre kolleginnen und kollegen
sind im dauereinsatz haben ein wenig
geschlafen können sie uns ein wenig die
die sicherheitslage
aktuellen jetzt ganz im moment in kiew
erläutern
soeben haben wir
wurden wir beschlossen von der luft
als sie haben sie sehen jetzt wir haben
das licht eingeschaltet
und wir arbeiten jetzt weiterhin
es gibt etwas was uns stört
die sirenen heulen permanent auf und des
personals permanent nach unten herr
doktor nach unten damit man sie nämlich
an einen sicherheitsraum oder einen
bunker unten in ihrem krankenhaus
vielleicht auch nur einen keller ich
würde auch gerne fragen wollen wie die
situation denn oben ist auf der straße
draußen tatsächlich wir sehen bilder von
einer quasi menschenleeren stadt wie
erleben sie kiew jetzt ganz aktuell
haben sie bereits auch russische
soldaten zum beispiel schon gesehen
nein wir noch nicht aber
in der staat erhört man dass geschossen
wird und
man hört auch explosionen
weil wir haben einen improvisierten
bunker
wir unser gebäude sehr alt
aus dem letzten jahrhunderte und wir
haben sehr tiefe täler
es ist zwar nicht gerade bequem aber wir
haben dennoch alle platz
leider müssen die bettlägerigen
patienten in den zimmern bleiben
und wir bieten immer anderen gott dass
er kein geschoss zu uns kommt
herr dr tiefe täler in einem krankenhaus
weil dem mann auch nie gedacht hätte
dass sie mal für diesen zweck gebraucht
werden müssten der metro mir also die
kof ganz herzlichen dank nach kiel und
alles gute und
an guten abend wo sie und wir bitten um
hilfe vielen dank
sprechen wir ganz kurz vor dieser
sendung aufgezeichnet wegen der
schlechten leitungs qualität unsere
reporterin katrin eigendorf ist jetzt
live in der westlichen zentral ukraine
kathrin wie würdest du ganz aktuell den
widerstand bewerten den die ukraine den
russischen truppen entgegenstellen
können
nun die situation entwickelt sich glaube
ich ganz anders als wladimir putin das
geglaubt hat der widerstand in die
ukraine der doch sehr sehr überlegen
russischen armee entgegen setzen ist
wirklich ziemlich stark putin muss davon
ausgehen dass er wenn er wirklich das
ziel erreichen will die regierung hier
abzusetzen sich einen ganz ganz
erbitterten krieg mit den ukrainischen
volk mit der ukrainischen armee liefern
muss und hier sind eben nicht nur die
streitkräfte sondern wirklich die breite
bevölkerung dabei ihr land zu
verteidigen wir haben das in den letzten
acht jahren die dieser krieg ja schon
dauert erlebt dass die ukrainische
bevölkerung mal ganz unabhängig von der
regierung immer bereit war für das land
einzutreten im moment haben wir hier so
eine stimmung dass viele leute sagen ja
wir haben angst wir haben sorge wir
haben sorge und unsere familie aber es
geht hier um unser land um die zukunft
der ukraine und wenn wir jetzt nicht für
unser land einstehen dann ist es im
prinzip für uns verloren so würde ich
die stimmung heute hier im land
beschreiben kathrin herzlichen dank für
diese an diese live aus der ukraine
das elend der menschen lässt sich auf
kalten taktischen landkarten nicht
darstellen und dennoch sind die wichtig
um einen überblick zu haben was da
gerade passiert
das ist die lage schauen wir sie uns an
russlands truppen greifen die ukraine
aus drei himmelsrichtungen an russische
panzer sind von belarus und dem
russischen grenzgebiet im nordosten aus
richtung kiew vorgerückt inzwischen
haben russische soldaten teile der
ukrainischen hauptstadt erreicht
carlo masala ist professor für
internationale politik an der bundeswehr
universität in münchen herr professor
willkommen zurück im heute-journal guten
abend ich
bin guten schönen guten abend herr
sievers was sagt ihnen diese aktuelle
verlauf des krieges über putins ziel
ich denke wir haben es noch immer mit
dem ziel zu tun in kiew die regierung
zum rücktritt zu zwingen die
kommunikationsanlagen der kleinlichen
streitkräfte vollständig zu zerschlagen
so dass diese nicht mehr in der lage
sind zu operieren und weiterhin halt den
dollars die erblasten zu besetzen und
die landbrücke von der krim zu zum
bombast zu schaffen präsident selensky
sagt er sein ziel nummer eins der russen
heißt das er muss auch aus ihrer sicht
um sein leben fürchten
also es ist sicherlich so und das ist ja
von putin mit mit einem begriff
entnazifizierung aus der deutlich gesagt
worden zielinski muss weg ob das leben
wird sein wird oder ob er sozusagen tot
aus einem präsidentenpalast ausgetragen
wird das werden wir letzten endes noch
sehen aber die beseitigung dieser
legitimen ukrainischen regierung ist das
ziel des russischen präsidenten ja jetzt
sagt der russische präsident heute er
sei auch bereit zu friedensverhandlungen
mit der ukraine unter bedingungen wie
ernst ist es zu nehmen
naja es gibt ja widersprüchliche
informationen aus moskau zunächst sagt
er ist bereit zu friedensverhandlungen
wenn die ukraine die kampfhandlungen
einstellt was letzten endes aber
kapitulationsverhandlungen sind dann
nimmt er es wieder zurück und fordert
die ukrainische armee auf den
präsidenten zu stürzen um zu putschen
also die signale in moskau sind
widersprüchlich sie deuten aber darauf
hin dass ihre korrespondenz ich schon
gesagt hat der russische vormarsch
erfolg nicht so reibungslos wie ihn der
russische präsident und die militärische
führung sich vorgestellt haben
geben uns noch mal ein bisschen in die
zukunft durch können so ein bisschen
durchführen was wladimir putin
möglicherweise plant in der ukraine ist
das eine militär operation quasi aus dem
lehrbuch
also sowohl gerade vorgegangen wird ist
es eine militäroperationen das sagen
auch eine fachleute aus denen sozusagen
russischen militärhandbuch also wir
haben den artilleriebeschuss wir haben
jetzt sozusagen heute gesehen luftlande
kräfte die versucht haben auch in kiew
etwas am präsidentenpalast zu machen
ihnen sozusagen zu umzingeln und wir
haben dann mechanisierte verbände also
von daher die militär operation läuft im
prinzip wie aus dem lehrbuch ist
taktischen verhaltens in kriegen mal
angenommen putin hätte damit dann
tatsächlich erfolg wie soll es dann aus
seiner sicht weitergehen plant er ein
marionettenregime in kiew einzusetzen
und kann man damit dann ein ganzes land
in schach halten
es ist schwierig zu sagen was er genau
plant ich würde mal vermuten er plant
die abtrennung sozusagen des dollars und
der krim also die krim ist ja schon
abgetrennt aber den mit der landbrücke
komplett von der ukraine und er plant
dann in kiew so eine art marionetten
regierung
er wird dieses land nicht kontrollieren
können mit diesen 200.000 truppen also
nicht eine vollständige besetzung der
ukraine wird nicht möglich sein vor
allen dingen nicht das halten dieser
ukraine und wenn man sich diese
militäroperationen ansieht dann bedeutet
das auch nicht darauf hin dass es hier
um die besetzung der ukraine geht aber
es geht in der tat um eine russland
angenehme russland freundliche regierung
in kiew und möglicherweise eine
dauerhafte abtrennung des ostens der
ukraine plus der krim in der ukraine
jetzt haben wir schon gehört dass putin
da möglicherweise doch auf mehr
widerstand stößt als er gedacht hat
können sie uns einen zeitrahmen geben
geht das ganze jetzt monatelang
jahrelang oder wie lange hält putin das
durch
nein ich glaube nicht dass es monate
lang und jahrelang gehen wird ich glaube
es ist eine sache von ein paar wochen
also die ukrainischen streitkräfte
leisten einen
wie ihre korrespondenten schon gesagt
hat bewundernswerten erbitterten
widerstand aber letzten endes angesichts
der russischen übermacht werden sie
nicht lange diesen widerstand aufrecht
erhalten können ich rechne er mit einer
operation die ein paar wochen dauern
wird als ein paar monate und ich rechne
auch damit dass zum beispiel die
bombardements aus der luft in den
nächsten tagen noch an intensität
zunehmen werden wenn die militärische
operation auf dem boden hält weiterhin
so schleppend verläuft wie sie jetzt
verläuft professor carlo masala
universität der bundeswehr auch heute
abend wieder herzlichen dank für ihre
expertise ich danke ihnen
die westliche welt ist entsetzt über das
war es wladimir putin da tut aber auch
in russland gibt es menschen die ebenso
entsetzt sind nur braucht man in
russland eine enorme portion mut um das
öffentlich zu sagen noch mal speziell
dann wenn der eigene präsident sich
entschieden hat das land in den krieg zu
führen das alles muss man wissen um zu
verstehen was es bedeutet das in über 50
städten überall in diesem riesigen land
vor allem viele junge leute auf die
straße gingen nein zum krieg riefen und
heute am tag danach damit beschäftigt
sind herauszufinden wo genau die
staatsmacht aldi festhält die ein
massives polizeiaufgebot von der straße
abgeführt hat annegret oster mit mehr
dazu
heute abend in moskau der krieg der nur
wenige hundert kilometer entfernt tobt
scheint weit weg und ist doch präsent in
den köpfen der menschen auf sehr
unterschiedliche weise
dies ist eine erzwungene entscheidung
einen anderen ausweg hat es nicht
gegeben
ich denke dass die menschen einfach
wenig informiert sind sie wissen nicht
was die wahrheit ist
ich werde das sicher nicht kommentieren
denn wir befinden uns doch in russland
gestern den tausende spontan auf die
straße um gegen den einmarsch in die
ukraine zu protestieren die polizei
greift hart durch nimmt nach angaben von
bürgerrechtlern mehr als 1700 menschen
fest
opposition ist gefährlich eine der
wenigen offen kremlkritischen zeitungen
russlands die nowaja gaseta vor wenigen
monaten bekam ihr chefredakteur den
friedensnobelpreis für seinen kampf um
die meinungsfreiheit auch jetzt findet
mitri morath auf klare worte
also zwischen leider muss ich bitteres
sagen am 24 februar
2022 wurde russland seine zukunft
genommen unser friedliebendes russisches
volk wird jetzt den hass der ganzen welt
zu spüren bekommen weil wir im zentrum
europas einen dritten weltkrieg beginnen
ein krieg ist immer auch ein kampf um
informationen und wie man an sie kommt
heute hat die russische medien auf sich
den zugang zum online netzwerk facebook
eingeschränkt
bringen wir unsere moskaus bald mit
dazugenommen
das ist jetzt die zahl der demonstranten
auf den straßen das ist natürlich eine
vergleichsweise kleine zahl wenn man die
große bevölkerung russlands als
vergleich nimmt kann man denn irgendwie
spüren wie die russen insgesamt
reagieren auf diesen krieg
ja also auf den ersten blick da wirkt es
wirklich so als spiele der krieg hier im
alltag eigentlich keine rolle aber es
gibt anzeichen dafür dass dem eben nicht
so ist ein beispiel dafür ist dass viele
menschen angefangen haben bargeld bei
den russischen banken abzuheben und das
spricht eher dafür dass sie sich sorgen
machen dass die sanktionen eben
auswirkungen haben könnten auf die
russische wirtschaft und auch auf ihre
ganz persönliche finanzielle situation
und dann ist es so dass wir bei den
straßen umfragen immer öfter hören dass
die menschen uns eben nicht ihre wahre
meinung sagen wollen aus angst danach
verhaftet zu werden das sagen sie
natürlich hinter vorgehaltener hand und
das zeigt eben dass zumindest ein teil
der begründung warum es hier nicht zu
einer breit angelegten anti kriegs
bewegung kommt darin zu sehen ist an den
einschüchterungen durch polizei und
geheimdienste dann sollten wir noch kurz
darüber reden was die russinnen und
russen überhaupt mitbekommen von alledem
was gerade in der ukraine vor sich geht
das in das wort invasion soll in den
staatsmedien ja gar nicht fallen
genau hier wird gesprochen von einer
friedensmission oder aber von einer
militärischen
spezialisten wiederholt das russische
staatsfernsehen eben die argumente der
russischen politiker und unterlegt diese
behauptungen dann mit den eigenen
berichten also zum beispiel wenn
wladimir putin davon spricht dass sich
in ukrainischen städten terroristen mit
artillerie waffen versteckt halten dann
zeigt das russische staatsfernsehen
die passenden bilder dazu woher die dann
kommen oder unter welchen umständen die
entstanden sind das können wir nicht
nachvollziehen klar ist nur dass sie in
einem wirklichen wieder widerspruch
stehen zu dem was uns aus unabhängigeren
aus verifizierbaren quellen erreicht und
es ist auch so dass in den russischen
talkshows ganz offen darüber diskutiert
wird ob man den ukrainischen präsidenten
zellen ski nicht vielleicht umbringen
sollte also dass fernsehpublikum das
wird hier ganz klar immer weiter auf
krieg eingeschworen interessante analyse
vielen dank
in berlin werden am sonntag 20.000
teilnehmer erwartet in köln am
rosenmontag zehntausende für frieden und
gegen den krieg der entscheidende
unterschied in der aktuellen lage
wladimir putin hat einen plan wir
versuchen gerade erst zu verstehen was
da passiert und ahnen bereits unser
altes europa ist geschichte eben weil
geschichte kein ende kennt auch wenn wir
das 1990 nach dem ende des kalten kriegs
dachten
unzählige krisensitzungen heute in
brüssel eu nato ein thema wie ist putin
zu stoppen wir beginnen mit der nato die
heute beschlossen hat ihre schnelle
eingreiftruppe zu verlegen
es wird ein neues europa geben düstere
worte waren das von jens stoltenberg dem
nato-generalsekretär in schönen guten
abend herr generalsekretär
training sie verlegen jetzt die nato
verlegt jetzt ihre schnelle
eingreiftruppe gen osten wohin genau
geschlossen
diese entscheidung umzusetzen die
aktivierung unserer verteidigungs plan
ist
das bezieht sich auch auf die
eingreiftruppe der nato wir werden diese
elemente
sehr schnell jetzt stationieren auf der
grundlage des rats von sack gehört dem
obersten oberbefehlshaber der nato die
entscheidung steht noch nicht genau fest
aber wir haben unsere präsenz im ostteil
des bündnisses vom baltikum bis runter
zum schwarzen meer verstärkt und wir
haben auch komponenten der
eingreiftruppe nicht zu land sondern
auch in der luft und zur see heißt dass
die nato fühlt sich auch bedroht durch
wladimir putin glauben sie wirklich dass
putin auch nato staaten angreifen könnte
werden als wichtig ist es doch für uns
einem überschwappen vorzubeugen
aus diesen unannehmbaren angriff auf die
ukraine man weiß es nicht ein angriff
könnt ihr der infektion entstehen und
wir wollen
missverständnis möglich lassen ist keine
falsche berechnungen anstellen deswegen
habe die präsenz in ost halten ist
aufgestockt und wir diskutieren noch
mehr truppen und soldaten dort
deutschland ist dabei sie haben gesagt
sie werden ihre präsenz erhöhen in
litauen
und deutschland hat auch der flugzeuge
stationiert dies in rumänien um neo frau
überwachung für die nato unterstützen
das tun wir um den konflikt nicht zu
provozieren sondern um ihn zu verhindern
und sicherzustellen dass russland ganz
klar versteht dass wir nichts mehr
erlauben werden und so kann man das am
besten tun sie haben gesagt sie möchten
nicht dass der konflikt über short quasi
dass es eine infektion gibt was meinen
sie denn damit genau welche gefahr
besteht aus nato sicht
wir haben hier bisher gesehen dass
russland bereit ist zur einsatz von
militärischer gewalt und seinen willen
durchzusetzen
rheine und sie hat noch forderungen
formuliert an die adresse der nato
hier sollte jede weitere erweiterung des
bündnisses beenden und ihr sollt alle
eure streitkräfte
abziehen
sind die staaten dieser
97 dabei sind und sie haben auch
deutlich macht denn wir das nicht
erfüllen diese russischen forderungen
das ist als die militärische
konsequenzen nennen geben soll wird und
absolut sicher zu sein dass ich
überhaupt keine möglichkeit gibt
irgendetwas falsch zu verstehen und dann
falsche berechnung hat so schnell über
unsere fähigkeit unsere bündnispartner
zu verteidigen deswegen stocken wir
unsere präsenz dort auf dem osten
russland muss verstehen dass die ukraine
dass die ukraine ein hochgeschätzter
fragen ist den wir unterstützen aber bei
bündnispartnern sieht es noch mal anders
aus mit deren sicherheit hier fand sie
hat gesagt in deutschland ist mit dabei
in litauen jetzt ist es allerdings so
dass die bundeswehr-soldaten die endeca
und aktuell schon stationiert sind
erschreckende
ausrüstungsmängel haben den vielen dicke
jacken und unterwäsche zum beispiel hat
die wehrbeauftragte heute gesagt wie
sehr kann man sich denn da aus nato
sicht auf deutschlands
verteidigungsfähigkeit verlassen
deutschland bei der verteidigung zur
kollektiven einsetzen welche
unterschiedliche art und weise
flugzeugen
schwarzmeer bereich aber auch wenn im
wald die kommt ihr habt eine kompetente
und professionelle
liter stehen das wissen wir und
verfolgen hier auch deutschland gehört
jetzt zum der verstärkten präsenz im
osten
wenn nicht sogar kurz unterbrechen da
haben sie sagen deutschland ist ein
wichtiger partner in der nato sie werden
aber auch mitbekommen haben dass gerade
gestern der heeresinspekteur der
bundeswehr folgendes gesagt hat in
seinem 41 dienstjahre im frieden habe er
nicht geglaubt noch einen krieg erleben
zu müssen und die bundeswehr das her das
ich führen darf steht mehr oder weniger
lang da hat der heeres inspekteur der
bundeswehr gesagt ist das
offenbarungseid ist das hilferuf was
machen sie aus diesem satz
es gibt
lücken
in der verteidigung streitkräften vieler
bündnisstaaten aber deswegen habe er
vereinbart mehr zu investieren aber
trotz dieser unzulänglichkeiten
trotz dieser lücken weiß ich dass sie
verteidigungskräfte deutschlands stark
sind oder fähigkeiten verfügen die von
größter bedeutung sind für unsere
kollektive verteidigung ich habe sie
gesehen mit eigenen augen ich hab sie
manöver gesehen ich habe sie in
afghanistan gesehen den baltischen
staaten
der deutsche beitrag zur nato ist
signifikant wird hoch geschätzt und er
gehört einfach zur kollektiven
verteidigung und die stärke der die nato
liegt darin dass wir zusammenstehen dass
ein angriff auf den 1
die reaktion des ganzen bündnisses
auslösen wir zusammenstehen werden wir
den frieden bewahren und konflikte
vermeiden die nato setzt auf deutschland
und die bundeswehr jens stoltenberg der
nato-generalsekretär vielen dank
ein vorhaben das
gespräch haben wir am abend
aufgezeichnet und bei der eu fällt wenn
es um eine reaktion des westens geht die
russland wirklich treffen würde gerade
immer ein wort
swift steht für
communication was für eine abkürzung das
ist ein internationales zahlungsnetzwerk
mit sitz in brüssel man kann auch sagen
dass es die geld autobahn ohne die in
der international vernetzten wirtschaft
nicht mehr viel geht anne gellinek jetzt
über die eu auf der suche nach antworten
schon dreimal haben die europäischen
außenminister und ministerinnen in
dieser woche zusammen gesessen zwei
sanktionspaket gegen russland
beschlossen und sich dann noch wladimir
putin und sergey lavrov vorgeknöpft
neben dem belarussischen diktator ist
putin nun der einzige präsident der welt
gegen den die eu sanktionen verhängt hat
nämlich auch den staatschef der
russischen föderation und den
außenminister
sanktionen belegen
konto einführungen innerhalb der
europäischen union das ist gegenüber
nato macht denn er macht einen land
trotz seiner ständigen sitz im
sicherheitsrat hat in der geschichte ein
einmaliger schritt den einen oder
anderen hatte vielleicht auch das live
gespräch mit dem ukrainischen
präsidenten beeindruckt aus dem von
russischen truppen umzingelten kiew
meldete er sich gestern abend beim
eu-gipfel
todes er hat uns gesagt dass er nicht
wisse ob er noch ein weiteres mal mit
uns sprechen könne
das war hart wir müssen uns immer den
ernst der lage im klaren sein die eu
also kontert und beschließt die bislang
härtesten strafmaßnahmen
ihr ziel die russische wirtschaft
langfristig zu schwächen beispiel
exportkontrollen zwei drittel der
russischen flugzeugflotte kommen aus dem
westen wenn jetzt keine ersatzteile mehr
geliefert werden könnten sie bald am
boden bleiben beispiel finanzmärkte die
eu-liste drei große russische banken die
künftig keine geschäfte mehr in europa
machen können die abkoppelung russlands
vom internationalen zahlungssystem swift
dagegen schieben die minister noch
einmal auf russlands finanztransaktionen
würden dadurch deutlich erschwert aber
auch europa hätte probleme außerdem
treffe man damit jeden bürger mit
kreditkarte und nicht die oligarchen
argumentiert deutschland
wir haben gesehen dass es eben eine
breitenwirkung hat anders als wenn wir
gezielt banken listen wirkt eine
entkopplung vom swift system in die
breite putin und la france dürfen
übrigens weiter in die europäische union
einreisen schließlich gibt es die
hoffnung dass man nach kriegsende wieder
miteinander reden könnte
wir zielen nicht auf die menschen in
russland wir unterscheiden ganz genau
zwischen dem kreml und russland putin
ist nicht gleich russland
wenn der krieg nicht aufhöre warnt
europas außenminister noch zum schluss
dann müsse man schon bald am dritten
sanktionspaket arbeiten vielleicht schon
nächste woche in brüssel
und vielleicht dann auch mit swift
damals noch mal kurz drüber reden ich
muss man das also vorstellen wie jemand
der meinl bank über also manager nur
dass es halt um billionen summen geht
gabriel felbermayr ist ökonom und ökonom
und direktor von wie vor dem
österreichischen
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitut der firma
guten abend guten abend herr sievers was
würde denn das bedeuten wenn russland
von swift abgeschnitten würde zunächst
mal für russland selbst
ja das würde bedeuten dass ist für
russland sehr kompliziert werden würde
internationale transaktionen zu tätigen
und zwar nicht nur mit den europäer oder
amerikaner sondern mit allen ländern die
in betrieb mit russland geschäfte machen
das würde also den außenhandel russlands
ganz massiv einschränken jetzt ist es
allerdings umgekehrt auch so dass
schulden die russland bei westlichen
banken hat dann ja auch nicht mehr
beglichen werden könnten da sind
österreichische banken sie sind unseres
wien zugeschaltet sehr betroffen und
wenn es für energielieferungen kein geld
mehr gibt dann wird es auch keine
energie lieferungen mehr geben also wie
sehr schneiden wir uns mit dieser swift
geschichte am ende ins eigene fleisch
es ist vollkommen klar dass sanktionen
die in russland auch wirklich schmerzen
hervorrufen auch bei uns solche
verursachen die idee dass man druck
ausüben kann in russland ohne der weise
wirtschaftlich osten zu haben diese idee
muss man leider verwerfen und was die
forderungen angeht muss man sagen das
geht in beide richtungen es ist nicht
nur so dass europäische banken und
unternehmen forderungen nach russland
haben umgekehrt gilt das auch und über
den verrechnungs weg könnte man die
westlichen unternehmen und europa
deutschland ist ein staatlicherseits da
kommt ist schon jetzt hat unser von der
leyen heute gesagt für die eu wir werden
stück für stück die industrielle basis
russlands abtragen das ist ein direktes
zitat ist das aus ihrer sicht der
richtige weg und erreichte eu das mit
den aktuellen sanktionen
ich weiß nicht was sie meint mit
industrieller basis abtragen die
sanktionen die jetzt beschlossen sind
können das nicht leisten er jedenfalls
nicht in absehbarer zeit natürlich ist
interessant
natürlich werden irgendwann mal als
teile fehlen in russland aber was wir
brauchen sind schnelle reaktionen und
deswegen meine ich wenn man wirklich
druck aufbauen will und
fähigkeit russlands ein streit mit der
ukraine krieg zu führen dann muss man
weitergehen da muss man an den
ausschluss des russischen bankensystems
vom westlichen systemdenken überschrift
oder chips oder oder andere wege jetzt
hat die eu heute auch beschlossen dass
sie die persönlichen konten von wladimir
putin und außenminister sergej lavrov
einfriert haben die beiden dann
überhaupt noch geld auf persönlichen
konnten sie wären dumm wenn sie da viele
hätten also ich denke das was man da
noch errichtet sozusagen das ist die
spitze des eisberges das gilt nicht nur
für die für die spitze der russischen
regierung sondern das gilt für alle
oligarchen wenn man glaubt man könnte
die jetzt finanziell belangen dann
täuscht sich wahrscheinlich die haben
ihre vermögen schon so organisiert dass
man darauf nicht mehr so leicht
zugreifen kann und haben das in länder
verschoben auf konten verschoben wo man
das nicht so leicht findet aber es ist
sicherlich notwendig wie ganz viele
anderen maßnahmen das zu tun einfach als
signal meinen sie natürlich kann man
natürlich wir können nicht nur sein
große vermögen in europa einfach liegen
lassen in dieser situation dass die
eingefroren werden wie das
gehört dazu es muss uns klar sein dass
wir dann
wirklich erwischt jetzt sagt man immer
ein rohstofflieferant wie russland einer
es der findet immer abnehmer egal welche
sanktionen es gibt ist da was dran
na ja also wir haben ja das
anschauungsmaterial aus dem iran das ist
auch ein rohstofflieferant und iran
wurde schon massiv getroffen durch genau
solche sanktionen die eben ihre anfang
weltfinanzsystem abgeschnitten haben
natürlich sicher da immer etwas durch
das ist klar aber wir haben keine
potentere waffe als mit solchen
maßnahmen voran zu gehen und was das
angeht das ist ja ein wichtiges
exportgut russlands die das ist bei
plant gebunden was nicht in den westen
geht kann nicht so einfach anders wohin
geleitet werden dann müsst ihr erst die
pipeline infrastruktur entstehen es geht
zur wege nach china aber die sind nicht
groß genug und die betreffen nicht die
westsibirische
lagerstätten insoferne das würde schon
wird professor trevor meier herzlichen
dank für diese analyse heute abend im
heute journal dann genau wie sehr gern
ja wir haben gerade schon gehört und
damit sind wir auch schon beim thema
china mag geografisch weit weg sein von
bukva ine konflikt ist aber so was wie
der elefant im raum übrigens eine
ursprüngliche russische sprach wendung
china beobachtet den russischen angriff
ganz genau und noch genauer wie der
westen darauf reagiert und all das aus
ganz eigenen gründen wie christiane
hoffmann zdf peking berichtet
viele sie mir putin und camping die
beiden mächtigsten autokraten der welt
ihrer allianz forderte den westen heraus
bringt die bisherige weltordnung ins
wanken china hält putin in seiner
aggression bisher den rücken frei hat
russlands vorwürfe an die nato als
angeblichen aggressor übernommen doch
präsident will offenbar auch als
vermittler wahrgenommen werden
das staatsfernsehen berichtete präsident
habe den russischen präsidenten zu
verhandlungen mit der ukraine
aufgefordert sie wolle dabei
unterstützen hieß es
china ist der meinung dass man nicht
mehr in dimensionen des kalten krieges
denken sollte sondern durch
verhandlungen einen ausgeglichenen
effektiven und nachhaltigen
sicherheitsmechanismus in europa
aufbauen
vor drei wochen hatten sich putin und zu
beginn der olympischen winterspiele
getroffen
demonstrativ eine strategische allianz
besiegelt gegen die nato und gegen die
usa
putin 90 mg betrachten den westen als
gespalten und schwach und im niedergang
die welt verliert den führer das waren
die worte die sie in einer erklärung im
februar verwendet haben die derzeitige
weltordnung kribbelt sie ist im
niedergang und es braucht einen neuen
führenden sie
eine strategische achse doch china
schlittert mit der unterstützung
russlands auch in ein dilemma der
autoritäre stadt tritt für souveränität
und nicht einmischung anderer länder ein
ist auch auf wirtschaftsbeziehungen mit
dem westen angewiesen
china hat größere bedenken über das
russische vorgehen entwickelt und was
das durch china selbst und die
beziehungen mit dem westen bedeuten
könnte ich denke dass es derzeit viele
interne debatten gelebt und soll
bewertungen und die von dieser allianz
in gewissem maße noch und lasst sie
und putin mit seinem krieg testet
russlands präsident auch diese allianz
wie eng sich die chinesen an ihn binden
werden hängt auch von der entschiedenen
reaktion des westens ab
da tut sich also etwas das unsere welt
verändern könnte die bisherige welt
zeigt sich in einem ehrwürdigen
sitzungssaal am east river in new york
und auch da ist china dabei und russland
auch der uno sicherheitsrat tagt noch in
dieser nacht zuständig eigentlich für
die wahrung des weltfriedens und
johannes hano in new york es könnte eine
sitzung werden die eine zeitenwende
markiert warum
dieser moment wird gerade hektisch
verhandelt nämlich um genau wie wir
schon gehört haben china auf die seite
der vereinten nationen zurück zu bringen
man versucht china zu überzeugen eine
resolution anzuerkennen denn es steht
viel auf dem spiel es geht nämlich darum
ob die alte weltordnung noch bestand hat
oder ob sie sich schneller auflöst als
man überhaupt eine möglichkeit hat eine
neue aufzug war nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg wurden die vereinten nationen
gegründet um diese menschheits
katastrophe krieg abzuwenden die
mitgliedsstaaten hatten sich
verpflichtet die einen angriffskrieg zu
verzichten die souveränität und
territoriale integrität aller staaten zu
akzeptieren eine friedliche lösung
durchzuführen und mit dieser resolution
heute wollen die usa und albanien alle
mitgliedsstaaten sozusagen zwingen farbe
zu bekennen unterstützen sie einen
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine durch russland oder
unterstützen sie die prinzipien der
vereinten nationen klar ist russland
wird diese resolution ablehnen klar ist
auch die mehrheit wird sich hinter
dieser resolution stellen aber die große
frage ist wie wird sich china wie wird
sich indien entscheiden wenn nämlich
zwei so große spieler in der welt einen
solchen angriffs krieg als mittel der
politik nicht ablehnen dann ist unsere
welt ordnung in auflösung begriffen
sollten sich china und indien aber
hinter diese resolution stellen dann ist
russland in der welt ziemlich isoliert
es steht also viel auf dem spiel auch
für die uno selbst johannes vielen dank
wir bleiben noch im moment bei der uno
die vereinten nationen stellen sich auf
bis zu vier millionen flüchtlinge aus
der ukraine ein sollte sich die
situation weiter verschlechtern
zigtausende sind bereits unterwegs
über die grenzen gen westen in
nachbarländer wie polen dessen
premierminister heute sagt seine grenze
ist auf für alle ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer und ausdrücklich so ergänzt er
noch auch für deren haustiere was hat
die steger ist für uns dort
warten und einfach weiter egal wie lange
es dauert auf der ukrainischen seite an
der polnischen grenze stauen sich die
autos und die menschen viele kilometer
flucht aus der ukraine
die bilder hat unser kollege lothar
becker gefilmt
auch sie wird warten in der kälte egal
wie lange es dauert kra in das ist auf
der polnischen seite der grenze und
hofft dass mutter und schwester es bald
zu ihr schaffen
warum wo ich
habe sehr große angst
nichts weil ich nicht will dass mein
land in solch einer situation ist
ernst du
sie fliehen vor dem krieg es sind vor
allem frauen und kinder weil die männer
zwischen 18 und 60 die ukraine nicht
verlassen dürfen verteidigen sollen
manche sind seit gestern unterwegs seit
den ersten russischen attacken
es fühlt sich an als wäre es schon eine
woche ich habe nicht geschlafen nichts
gegessen das ist das einzige wasser in
zwei tagen
polen helfen und ukraine die schon in
polen neben witali erklärt wo sie hilfe
finden wo
transportmöglichkeiten sind ich weiß wie
die situation in der ukraine ist meine
familie hat dort aus ich muss einfach
hier helfen im polnischen grenzort
chemische ist endlich der zug aus odessa
angekommen die züge aus der ukraine
stundenlang verspätet immerhin kommen
noch welche raus
wir sind mit dem nötigsten gekommen wir
hoffen dass das alles aufhört und wir
wieder nach hause gehen können das
konzert auch
hier hilfsbereitschaft putin wütet im
nachbarland sorgen kommen auf die längst
vergessen schienen russland das ewige
schreckgespenst polens
wissen wir denn dass wir nicht auch bald
in dieser situation sind auf vielen und
hilfe suchen und
an der grenze treffen wir auch immer
wieder ukraine die in polen wohnen und
in die andere richtung gehen in den
krieg
ja ich gehe nach hause ich bin doch
militärisch verpflichtete us börsen so
viele aber wollen raus aus der ukraine
und die die warten ob und wann ihre
liebsten es schaffen trösten sich
gegenseitig
wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
helfen wollen dann können sie das tun
beim aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine hier ist
die bahn dazu de 65 104 106 100 104 106
100 und all das auch noch mal zum
nachlesen unter spenden zdf de oder im
zdf textseite 890 und wir bleiben auch
noch einen moment beim thema hanna du
hast weitere nachrichten dazu gebündelt
bundespräsident steinmeier hat den
einmarsch russlands in die ukraine
scharf verurteilt und den russischen
präsidenten dazu aufgerufen die angriffe
zu beenden
präsident putin
vergisst es blut jenes volkes
dass er eben noch bruder volk nannte
ich appelliere an präsident putin
stoppen sie den wahnsinn dieses krieges
jetzt in seiner ansprache sagte
steinmeier außerdem dass putins handeln
nicht ohne deutliche antwort bleiben
könne
und wir kommen zur wirtschaft und
blicken auf die finanzmärkte gestern
noch war der dax auf talfahrt wegen des
ukraine kriegs heute sei das dagegen
schon wieder anders aus valerie haller
an der frankfurter börse die sorgen sind
ja eigentlich groß burg kommt dieses
plus ja das ist die hoffnung auf ein
baldiges ende des krieges die börsianer
reagierten auf das angebot des kremls
mit der ukraine verhandeln zu wollen
auch sind die sanktionen bislang nicht
so scharf ausgefallen wie man hier
erwartet hatte also der schaden für die
europäische wirtschaft so hofft man hier
vermutlich überschaubar der dax mit
eindrucksvolle aufholjagd wieder
deutlich über 14.000 punkten dass die
erholung wirklich von dauer ist eher
fraglich die wirkliche tragweite des
krieges in der ukraine ist hier noch gar
nicht eingepreist weil sie niemand
abschätzen kann viele schauen auf öl und
gas russland und die ukraine sind aber
auch große lieferanten von wichtigen
vorprodukten dünger zum beispiel
entscheidend für die landwirtschaft aber
auch industriemetalle und edelgase die
notwendig sind für die herstellung von
ganz vielen industrieprodukten beispiel
chip-produktion diese lichtblitze wären
ohne das gas neon nicht möglich ein
wichtiges vorprodukt das größtenteils
aus der ukraine kommt gleichzeitig ist
russland großer produzent von palladium
das metall wird in der sensoren und
speicher produktion verwendet anleger
haben heute durchgeschnauft der krieg in
der ukraine so vieles klar wird erstmal
das bestimmende thema an den börsen
bleiben heftige kursausschläge
inbegriffen danke valerie nach frankfurt
trotz sinkender corona zahlen waren
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
weiterhin zur vorsicht und vor zu
schnellen öffnungs schritten vor allem
wegen der ausbreitung des omikron unter
typs ba2 könnten die fallzahlen auch
wieder steigen lauterbach sagte dass
aktuell an einer neufassung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes gearbeitet
werde denn auch ab dem 20 märz würden
klassische schutzkonzepte und regeln für
hot spots gebraucht
der hessische ministerpräsident volker
bouffier hat seinen vorzeitigen
rücktritt angekündigt ende mai wird er
sein amt zur verfügung stellen zudem
wurde entschieden wer sein nachfolger
werden soll und zwar der bisherige
landtagspräsident boris rhein am 31 mai
wird er sich im parlament zur wahl
stellen rhein soll außerdem der neue
landesvorsitzende der cdu werden
heute ging's los für das deutsche team
zu den paralympischen spielen in peking
die 18 athletinnen und athleten
starteten am abend vom flughafen
frankfurt am main zu den
medaillenhoffnungen gehört mono
skifahrerin anna lena forster die
letzten vier mal gold bei der wm im
januar holte ab märz sollen die spiele
in peking beginnen
im krieg erleben wir das schrecklichste
was menschen zu tun im stande sind und
gerade im krieg sehen wir immer auch das
was menschlichkeit ausmacht stellen sie
sich an hotel four in hq krah ine direkt
an der front verängstigte einwohner
haben sich dort versammelt suchen
gemeinsam eine möglichkeit zur flucht
während die raketen fliegen setzt sich
ein junger ans klavier
[Musik]
eine reporterin der washington post hat
diesen moment gefilmt ist es die melodie
aus tales from the loop einer serie in
der eine maschine die rätsel des
universums entschlüsseln soll es ist die
hoffnung auf eine bessere welt
die aktuelle haben wir ihnen in diesem
heute-journal zusammengefasst vielen
dank dass sie mit uns dabei war jetzt
von markus lanz auch hier das thema der
krieg in der ukraine und zu gast ist
unter anderem jürgen trittin und danach
gegen 23.30 gibt es dann ein
verlängertes heute-journal update mit
nah sein möchte mehr von unserem ganzen
team hier in redaktion produktion in der
regie danke fürs zuschauen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
schokolade und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter in den nächsten woche gibt es
viel sonnenschein und das geht schon
morgen los allerdings gibt es noch an
den alpen einige schneefälle und sowie
im osten ebenfalls noch etwas lässt aber
allmählich nach und das in der bereits
in der kommenden nacht schauen wir in
die nacht oder gibt es in der ersten
nachthälfte noch einige schneeschauer
sogar noch gewitter auch an den alpen
fallen noch einige flocken aus den
wolken ansonsten aber klar dass auf und
es wird teilweise glatt bei temperaturen
fast überall unter der null-grad-marke
werte also von 0 bis -4 grad häufig
anzutreffen im osten zwei grad plus an
der see ein grad genauso wie im südosten
so gerade frostfrei morgen im
tagesverlauf lassen die schneeflocken
dann an den alpen nach und auch dort
wird es trockener sonst gibt es kompakte
wolken aber es ist trocken von
nordwesten her setzt sich nach und nach
die sonne durch temperaturen dazu mit
einem grad an den alpen am kältesten
morgen sonst am mildesten mit neun bis
zehn grad etwa richtung niedersachsen ja
die nächsten tage am sonntag noch letzte
harmlose wolken ansonsten sehr viel
sonnenschein bei temperaturen bei drei
bis elf grad und montag verbreitet sonne
vier bis elf dienstag ein ticken wärmer
mit zwölf grad aber dafür im westen mit
regen damit ein schöner abend